I'll open a very warm welcome indeed to
this latest edition of quadriga coming
to you from the heart of the German
capital Berlin and today we're looking
at the eagerly awaited referendum just
days away now on Britain's future in
Europe where the latest polls suggest
that the brig's ik camp has a slight
lead its supporters say they want to
cast off the shackles of Brussels give
us our country back is their battle cry
the remain camp meanwhile says a bitter
divorce could wreak havoc on the British
economy and put the very future of the
EU at risk the only thing that seems
certain this vote is that it looks set
to remain very tight and very tense and
so our question here today on quadriga
is should the UK stay or go and to
discuss that question I'm joined here in
the studio by three seasoned observers
and analysts beginning with Derrick
Scully who is from the Irish Times and
who says brexit is merely a symptom for
a long deep-seated EU illness that saw
all critics of the bloc branded
Euroskeptics and pushed into the
isolation ward also with us is Alan
Posner a regular commentator for the
berlin-based de Velde newspaper who
believes brexit would be a catastrophe
and not only for Britain as it would
lead to the dissolution of the European
Union he's not inked as I say that and
welcome to two Ulrika Hammond a business
editor and writer at another Berlin
Daily the targets I took or tats
Arica says have brought a brexit
wouldn't be as bad as it seems for the
EU because the British would in any case
be forced to adopt all the key EU laws
to begin with you because you say a
disaster might be just days away tell us
about the disaster the disaster goes
like this
Britain leaves there's a disaster in
that in that in that a man like Brice
Johnson might become Prime Minister
which is disaster in itself for Britain
I'll talk about Europe then the no camp
the anti-european camp in places like
France France over 61 percent of the
population are again to have unfavorable
Appeals of the EU demand a referendum
there in Denmark they demand a
referendum
where there's also an anti European
party has more votes in any other party
in Poland people demand a referendum and
the whole thing starts to fall apart the
whole project starts to fall apart
Germany is left with a few rump states
hoping for handouts from the German
table and that is cast as the European
Union which in fact is just basically a
neo-colonial project this I admit is the
worst possible outcome but it's not
totally unrealistic that's a terrible
thing Ulrika do you buy into this in any
way and no I don't because you know
politically Germany here it might be
divided but it kind of economically we
are bound to be good together it's a
very small continent with very tight
economic exchanges it's impossible to
somehow get independent economically and
that's something I think the British are
going to realize because look at
countries like Norway or Switzerland or
Iceland they do not belong to the EU but
nonetheless they are forced to to
implement all European laws in order to
be able to trade with the European Union
and the same mall as the same would
happen to Britain I mean they would be
no longer part of the EU but in order to
trade with the EU to have economic
contacts with the EU they would have be
forced to implement all the European
laws and the only difference would be
that they are no longer able to take a
political part in deciding on these laws
it's a fallacy you know since the days
of Karl Marx who was a very German
person
well the economics determines everything
you have Europe was a tight tightly knit
economic unit before the First World War
and they threw it all away
they destroyed this and we haven't
recovered from that since Europe you
know Europe is totally capable of just
of self destructing once the demons of
European nationalism are unleashed and
this is what is going to happen if the
if if if the breaks of people win
that's what
I'm worried about and if German sit back
compressively and say no they're gonna
have to take the medicine you know like
mr. Schuyler said the German Finance
Minister they're gonna have to you know
like you just said they're gonna have to
accept everything we decide they just
won't have any say anymore you don't
understand how everywhere in Europe
except from except for Germany itself
people's blood begins to boil at that
you know that this is what is destroying
Europe
let's bring Tareq in yes this is I would
be with Orica that it's butter for Haman
at this point if we didn't have what was
going on what was what Allen is
described we've got this populism and
nationalism this toxic mix spreading
around Europe so the time for
rationalism and the time for rational
debate in the notion that Europe is some
rules-based construct that the rules
will continue to work and it's like a
sort of a clockwork that will just keep
ticking and Britain will be at a smaller
wheel in this clockwork mechanism that
is on paper that's how it should be but
we have got from Murray in the pen we've
got populist in Austria in Sweden in
Finland in Denmark rising in Germany and
we're sort of in a post reality based
part of European history at the moment
and it's emotion that is now driving
things and people are this is anti
elitist feeling this is it's almost like
the Donald Trump feeling we're in a very
unhappy place at the moment and if you
start tinkering with the clockwork at a
time like this that's where I think that
you will never get this clock working
again after the the brexit vote I mean I
agree is on is that of course there's
lots of nationalism and emotion that's
now deciding the fate of Britain but I
mean what are we supposed to do as a
European Union I mean you two you agree
that those a UK guys are not pursuing
irrational policy now how is Europe
supposed to react to irrationality you
see what is the sort of pose to be the
politics we as as Germans I mean you
always address me as a German so what
are the Germans supposed to do well I
mean if they are all irrational those
who died five years ago differentiating
between insane Euroskeptics and
intelligent your
critics in Britain and there are many of
them and Berlin until recently decided
that anyone who criticized the European
Union was anti-european
let's put them in the bad corner and
this has been it for me and very
frustrating part of the European Union
in the last 10 years that criticism just
was like a Teflon coating in Brussels it
just was just it just sensible European
critics in Britain some of the most
sensible that I've heard very rational
intelligent people and they have never
been listened to and certainly in the
last real we have Britain being listened
to in Berlin and say oh yes this and
this is a good idea why don't we do that
well it's obviously tell me what exactly
would have had to change in Europe in
order to somehow improve the situation
in Britain my perspective is completely
different
everything that Britain wanted has been
done by the EU and you know that's a
problem there is not one single proposal
even not from Cameron what the EU should
do in order to keep Britain within the
EU you know my impression is the whole
debate in Britain doesn't have anything
to do with the reality of the EU it's
completely about Britain and the
situation there and before we continue
let's just let's just before we continue
about the British perception of the EU
and and and the gripes that the British
have about de about Brussels let's hear
a little bit from the brexit campaign
beginning specifically with the Thomas
man of the year the brexit campaign
Boris Johnson to Brussels some of which
he spent by friends you know some of
which is spent on Spanish bullfighting
do you think the British taxpayers
should be supporting Spanish
bullfighting is certainly not a
democracy laws are framed and instigated
by the European Commission it is just
very frustrating having Cicero
constantly to deal with a barrage of
just mindless petty rules it's
completely mad I actually think that the
EU should have a huge warning sign on
the top of it saying contains nuts
so our message is going to be loud and
clear
we don't plus a European Union passport
we want a British passport
we want our passports back we want our
borders back we want our country back we
want to make June the 23rd Independence
Day don't we
Derek Nigel for hours they're talking
about Independence Day saying
specifically but we want our borders
back we want our country back is that
just right-wing populism be the kind of
thing that one can dismiss or should we
be taking it seriously as you appear to
be arguing half the British really lost
their sovereignty and ceded it to
Brussels they believe they have and not
this I think as for Hammond said it's
all about perception and what actually
what if you listen to what he's actually
saying is we want the Empire back we
want to be somebody again and we feel
that Brussels has taken our pride from
us our importance Britain lost it long
before joined the EU and it would have
even less importance in the world I
believe if it hadn't been in the EU the
British believe quite sincerely I think
you know I was there again recently I
was speaking to an awful lot of people
and they believed that their their
democracy is much more open much more
accessible much more transparent much
more lively much more authentic than
Brussels they've got a case of a well
what is Brussels Brussels is British
politicians going to Brussels and making
decisions or telling the European
Commission we would like you to come up
with a rule on vegetables which they
then mock in London and saying all the
processes coming up with these crazy
rules for vegetables which London and
other capitals demanded so and Britain
is projecting a lot of this a
self-loading is at play here I believe
and this sort of read this irrationally
that somehow we will be somebody again
we can make Britain great again like
Donald Trump is saying let's make
America great again by somehow cutting
off our nose to spite our face then
they'll listen to us when we have no
nose left and this this this for 35
years the British press the Murdoch
press has been very slowly very
consistently at doing two things
attacking the BBC and attacking Europe
and if you've been raised in this
environment
everyone who's Pro Europe or pro-eu in
Britain is on the backfoot and they have
been for 30 years you're constantly
under defense you're constantly
defending why this is a good thing
as opposed to in Germany which is the
other way around and that has finally
Rupert Murdoch is now going to have his
day and this is what he's been investing
in all these years to try and get
Britain where he wants it which is out
of the European Union and if you've been
bombarded with these message for 30
years it seems completely normal and
that is their bubble in which Britain is
leaving in in living and that's their
decision to but this that the
environment in which they're deciding
couldn't be less conducive and that's
this this what what will happen then
across Europe and that's really the
spark and in the gas filled room going
to point to point taken let's shift
shift gear or shift focus Allen just a
little bit too little sovereignty
because too much of it has been given
away say they say the brexit camp too
much immigration is there too much
immigration no I mean Britain has
profited immensely from from immigration
from Europe take the polls for instance
for people from Poland take the view
from I haven't take bankers from France
businessman from Germany and so on so
obviously in fact many people in Britain
would rather have more immigration only
from other countries from some from
China from Russia from the Caribbean
from Pakistan and so on so no this this
is this is that there is no rational
argument I agree
for Britain leaving the European Union
the point is however that we are beyond
the point of rational argument and if
British people went British people look
to Europe they see for instance Greece
being brought to its knees by the German
Finance Minister they see Spain being
brought to its knees by austerity on the
behest of Berlin 40 percent of youth
unemployment they see a eurozone with
zero growth whereas their own country is
over two percent growth so they are
worried that if this goes on this will
happen to him it's not just nostalgia
it's not just negatives there's also
positives if 50 percent of the British
people vote for the brexit then they
clearly believe that they can go it
alone do you understand what makes them
so confident that they can do that it's
not just negatives here surely well I
think it's in it's in part
sort of
feeling that you know there's this
transatlantic a feeling the the
Anglosphere which encompasses Australia
New Zealand the United States and so on
obviously this is more a dream than a
reality but I can understand where they
come from because obviously you know if
you're a British musician or actor or
businessperson like like like Sir
what's-his-name Branson who do the
Virgin Airlines you do automatically
find your way or if you're a journalist
like Tina Brown you-you-you do find your
way to the United States whereas Germans
find it very difficult to do so so so
there is you know but that Obama you
know we put pay to that you know
President Obama went to Britain said you
won't have more influence if you leave
Europe you'll have lessened go to the
back of the queue when it comes to
negotiating privileges so you I can
understand where this comes from it's
not just old Empire it's an old feeling
of the english-speaking peoples which
Winston Churchill spoke about lonely
together and defending democracy I think
it's an illusion but it's no it's
certainly no no coincidence that that
Boris Johnson is a biographer Winston
Churchill I mean he's like a public
caricature of the great man but you know
that that's where he gets his ideas from
arica you talks pragmatically about the
British then after they voted themselves
out of the EU turning back to the EU and
very inviting themselves into the club
according to the Norwegian or the Swiss
models yeah do you think that really is
going to work and a lot of people say
that the EU works it simply won't go
with that anymore well I don't think so
because once you know there is this
brexit of course the EU will try to keep
Britain is close to the EU as possible
but I think the real problem will be
that the brexit will not be a clear-cut
decision because even if there is a
decision for the brexit it will be by
margin let's say of two percent now two
percent is nothing in political terms
now and after the breaks a vote for the
brexit you'll have two years of
negotiations with EU during this time
there will be a lot of uncertainty which
I think will be an causing economic
in Britain so probably during those two
years of negotiation quite a lot of
Brits will think well it might not have
been such a good idea to vote for the
Praxis so then when it finally comes to
leaving you will have polls showing that
most of the Brits would rather stay and
in the end you know it might be that
Britain will stay and the only victim
will be David Cameron who of course will
be forced to resign if there was a
majority for a brexit however small the
battle by calling this Boris Johnson
which would be a problem just as ounces
and Britain within the EU that is a
possibility you know it's I should yeah
I think it's a very different no it's no
it would be crazy to think that a very
very very small margin in favor of a
brexit would automatically lead to
Britain leaving that I think is not how
politic works okay what Arica is talking
about if there is a brexit vote what
happens next and nothing that we
couldn't deal with is what the brig's it
the briggsie tears appeal to appear to
be saying meanwhile the remain camp says
that there will be major worries perhaps
disaster for Europe and the UK the storm
is brewing over the Isles the brexit is
now a fact Britain is getting out
the European Union faces the biggest
crisis in its history the bloc has lost
a major military power and its
third-largest net income contributor but
after the party it's time to pay the
piper the economy in Britain shrinks an
estimated six percent experts say around
800,000 jobs are in jeopardy it's ground
zero for a political explosion all over
the continent the hour has struck for
Euroskeptics and they start to push for
exits too Prime Minister David Cameron
falls on his sword and resigns he's
succeeded by leave frontman Boris
Johnson a former mayor of London and
what does the rest of the Union do draw
together or fall to pieces
Ellen we're shaking ahead while you were
listening to the report tell me why
well I agreed I agree that the scenario
seems to me very realistic especially
the part about what happens to Europe in
falls apart it doesn't draw together
this is what you know this is what
missus Roybal is hoping this is what the
Social Democrats are this were all
lefties in Germany opening that finally
without these pesky Brits we become you
know the ever close Union we always
wanted to have but nobody in Europe and
most people in Germany don't want once
that much you know this is not going to
happen
Europe is gonna fall apart politically
and the idea you know that oh we're this
economic union we can't do this you know
Europe is destroyed itself time and
again and by the way had to be rescued
by Great Britain twice you know it's
true right so you can do it again I mean
without the Brits when we talk about
dire threats Donald Tusk the President
of the European Council came out earlier
this week and said our enemies will open
the champagne if Britain leaves which
enemies do you think he was referring to
Derek he was referring to people who are
in very good positions to win elections
in the next two years in in Europe I
mean breaks it is only the first
election we've got the presidential
election in France we've got we've we've
just had a presidential election in
Austria and Obie's will be parliamentary
elections coming there in Germany we've
got federal elections coming next year
with an unheard-of double-digit growth
for for a new populist right-wing party
playing a lot of this playing a lot of
this a anti-european rhetoric so it's
going to be hay day for payday for this
anti elitist anti-european
mix that we're just saying it sort of it
sort of a mongrel movement around Europe
each have their own color but it's
that's exactly what it's this this
growing this rising damp of nationalism
is coming up through the walls and
that's what we're facing yeah I think
that's true that there is an entire
elite elite sentiment and whole of
Europe but that's not because there is
in you and you the problem is that in
most of the countries there has been a
long period of neoliberal policy
which always meant that the rich get
richer and that the poor get poorer and
of course that's what people are
revolting against but that doesn't have
anything to do with the EU for example
Britain itself has a very neoliberal
policy when it comes to enriching the
rich and making the poorer even more
poor and so you know the if you wanted
to somehow defeat those populist parties
you'd have to do let a social democratic
policy in the old sense trying to make
people feel more secure economically but
that's not going to happen instead we
have a new liberal Parliament's and so I
share you feel your fears but I don't
think that it has had anything to do
with Europe and that's the problem well
first the question who Mister Donut risk
was referring to he's a poll we know
he's referring to he's referring to
Russia I've just been on a trip for a
week through the three Baltic republics
Sonja Latvia and Lithuania and these
people are shaking in their boots for
fear of what Russia will do with their
Russian mine or with their own Russian
minorities there and what Russia is
doing mr. Putin has already declared
himself the protector of these Russian
monitors we're seeing what Russian
hooligans do on the streets of France
encouraged by their own politicians this
is what Europe is facing this is why the
EU needs to keep together this is why we
must combat the whole these this idea of
of nationalism but I want to say one
thing it is not neoliberal policies as
you know proposed by Great Britain which
is driving European Europe apart it has
been the attempt to hold the Euro
together at the cost of the poor nations
of Europe driven by a grand coalition in
in in in Germany which is driven Europe
I agree that's the German policy coming
to the event when it's dealing with the
euro is completely nonsense but you
cannot tell me that the Brits who are
not part of the euro want to leave the
EU because of the German policy
regarding the euro that's just I'd say
it ain't nonsense because it's rather
that the poop people in Britain think
that somehow their situation is due to
those immigrants from East Europe let me
cut between you two and just go to Gary
we're running out of time Derek I would
just give you a minute to minute enough
to tell us how much dismay there will be
in Ireland north and south of the border
if there is a brexit vote phrase it is
disaster does not feature it in the
debate at all but we have a border with
Northern Ireland which is a completely
open border Belfast is an hour from
Dublin trade back and forth if Britain
leaves it's now an outer EU border and
the question is do we put a barbed wire
again we put up soldiers it don't be a
customs border the very least which
means cost which means queues which
means the whole peace process the whole
economic growth the prosperity that
oiled the peace process will be called
into question that calls into a lot into
questions so that the Ireland could
actually be one of the first casualties
of this debate and this breaks it throat
and it's not really being debated in
Britain at all we'll see how well that
goes yeah absolutely it's I mean it's a
disaster for Ireland and disaster for
the peace process you've said it it's a
disaster for the Baltic States for
Poland I mean you name it it's it's
terrible the question that I asked at
the top of the show the UK should the UK
stay or go give me your summarizing
comments should the UK stay or go of
course they should stay and I think they
vote for not leaving mm-hmm
I also believe self-interest will
prevail at the end and the holiday home
province will beat their sense of
wounded pride that Brussels is dictating
their lives I hope they're afraid enough
of Boris Johnson as a prime minister I
mean I'm he's an okay novelist right
yeah but mediocre but okay but as a
prime minister it'd be a disaster he's a
he's a he's an actor he's not a
politician I hope that fear of Boris
Johnson is it instructive that the name
Boris Johnson gets mentioned in the same
sentence as Donald Trump on many
occasions in recent debates no no no
Donald Trump's is a horrible
is really a nasty person Boris Johnson
is a nice person he's just a bad
politician mm-hmm and let me go one last
word Derek on this do you what we're not
which way do you want it to go which way
do you think it's going to go because
the book there there are the book makers
on one side and the pollsters on the
other side who's right because the
pollsters say that there's going to be a
brexit vote the book makers stay that
people are going to on the side of
caution well I'm hoping that the Irish
voters will get out in Britain they're
entitled to vote there and they could
swing it one way or the other and they
were swingers or remain I could be if
it's tight it could be something like
that so all our voters have been ordered
in Britain to go ahead and vote on
referendum day ok thanks very much
thanks for being here thanks for
providing our viewers with so much food
for thought I hope you've enjoyed the
show as much as I have if you have get
in touch with us we like to hear from
you mail or social media and do come
back next week until then bye bye